bienvenidos a este espacio de salud de
france 24 el 10 de septiembre se
conmemora el día mundial de la
prevención del suicidio y en este
programa queremos abordarlo como un
problema social como un problema también
complejo que nos atañe a todos cada 40
segundos una persona en el mundo pierde
la vida a raíz del suicidio y solo en el
continente americano son 97 mil las
personas que se suicidaron en 2019
además se calcula que por cada persona
que realmente se ha suicidado al menos
20 lo han intentado
para hablar del tema nos encontramos en
la sede de la línea 106 es una línea de
orientación emocional de escucha y
también de apoyo psicológico como en
bogotá igual que en otras partes del
mundo o de américa latina' el suicidio a
veces sigue siendo un problema que queda
invisibilizado pero que aquí conocen de
cerca nos acompaña a adriana art y la
ella es la subdirectora en determinantes
de salud de la secretaría de salud de
bogotá muchas gracias por acompañarnos
hoy queríamos preguntarle muchas veces
el suicidio se presenta como una cosa
individual como una tragedia que queda
de puertas adentro como explicamos que
en verdad se trata de un problema de
salud
es un problema de salud pública por dos
grandes raciones razones su
comportamiento en cifras y el impacto
que genera claro para el individuo la
familia y para la sociedad en su
conjunto en bogotá en términos de cifras
el intento la amenaza y el suicidio
consumado han tenido un comportamiento
histórico al ascenso no sólo en la
ciudad en el país y en el mundo la
tendencia al incremento progresivo y
hubo digamos una disminución en cifras
en pandemia pero en parte se explicaba
porque no se estaba registrando el
fenómeno en la medida que los servicios
de salud dejan de captar casos para
atender la pandemia pero ahora que
volvemos a las re aperturas nuevamente
estamos observando esta tendencia al
incremento y en términos del impacto
familiar personal y social fue son
implicaciones tan amplias tan amplias
que no sólo en la salud sino que
trascienden batalla doctor ardila
cuéntenos también sabemos que el
suicidio es una cosa que es prevenible y
que es tratable que le hace falta a las
instituciones instituciones como esta
por ejemplo para llegar a todas esas
personas que necesitan atención y que
necesitan tratamiento es fundamental
trabajar en red de manera intersectorial
no es sólo salud esto es una
problemática social y la esperanza en
salud mental se construye de la mano
entre todos y fortalecer todos los
procesos desde la prevención la
promoción de la salud la atención muy
fuerte tanto en instituciones como muy
importante en comunidad y domiciliaria y
la rehabilitación que una parte de según
la singularidad el individuo pero la
otra vez acciones en colectivo
sectoriales e intersectoriales en estas
oficinas de la línea 106 hay una
veintena de psicólogos que trabajan
diariamente en atender el llamado de los
bogotanos y de las bogotanas que
necesitan alguien que los escuche son
profesionales que trabajan en la
promoción de la salud mental pero
también en la prevención de distintos
problemas entre ellos el suicidio para
hablar de esto estamos con edwin
gonzález uno de los psicólogos de la
línea 106 muchas gracias por
acompañarnos hoy gracias por
es bien cuéntanos cuando alguien los
contactos con y de acciones suicidas que
es lo primero que les dicen lo más
importante es invitar a la persona que
exprese cualquier situación malestar y
conformidad que esté presentando en su
vida generalmente un pensamiento de
muerte no está asociado a una situación
específica o incluso a veces no es
posible detectar la de forma tan fácil
por eso es que es importante invitarlo a
que exprese sobre cualquier situación
que esté presentándose en su vida que se
motive a expresar esa esa atención
emocional esa cantidad de pensamientos
que tiene en ese momento de tal manera
que pueda a través de esa expresión
poder
de terminar de mejor forma que lo que
está pensando pasando en ese momento
cuál es una de las principales ideas
erróneas que cree que hay en los medios
y entre la sociedad respecto al suicidio
que usted desde su experiencia práctica
sabe que no son reales pero el principal
mito es creer que el suicidio se
presenta únicamente en personas que
sufren algún tipo de trastorno mental o
que están pasando por alguna situación
de gran afectación en su vida una
pérdida económica una pérdida de
sentimental cuando no una una idea
suicida puede presentarse ante cualquier
circunstancia en cualquier momento de la
vida por eso es importante tener
presente la oportunidad de poder hablar
de ese tema de forma abierta de tal
manera que una persona si llega a tener
pensamientos de muerte lo puede expresar
de forma clara en cualquier momento sin
ningún temor entonces para ayudar
también a las personas que nos están
viendo de qué señales tenemos que estar
pendientes para cuidar las personas de
nuestro alrededor que podrían estar
teniendo estas ideas de muerte bueno
generalmente cualquier tipo de cambio en
la rutina en las formas de expresión
verbal una forma de expresión emocional
que genera la alarma por ejemplo
a
manifestar pensamientos de desesperanza
pensamientos de minusvalía es decir
considerar que no vale para sí mismo que
no vale para las demás personas que
todas sus acciones terminan en un
fracaso pueden ser señales de que puedan
estar elaborando pensamientos de muerte
que aún no ha entendido de forma clara
entonces es importante tener vigilancia
cualquier tipo de este tipo de camps la
percepción que existe alrededor del
suicidio no siempre se corresponde con
la realidad y por eso hemos preparado
una lista de mitos que queremos
desmontar para empezar a romper con la
está vuestra
se cree que preguntarle a alguien si
está pensando en suicidarse puede
incitar le a hacerlo sin embargo
preguntar puede ser la forma más
efectiva que tenemos de prevenirlo
además de escuchar con respeto otra idea
que está extendido es que un intento de
suicidio busca llamar la atención en
realidad es una muestra de sufrimiento y
señala la necesidad de tratamiento y
acompañamiento además aunque creamos que
el suicidio es algo impulsivo que no se
dice la gran mayoría de las personas que
se suicidan han dado señales claras o
han expresado antes su intención de
hacerlo finalmente muchos creen que los
medios de comunicación deben guardar
silencio sobre el suicidio para no
provocar un efecto llamada en realidad
informar con rigor mostrará alternativas
y no centrarse en casos específicos
puede ayudar precisamente a prevenirlo
con este último mito que apela a que
hablemos ya que pongamos este tema sobre
la mesa cerramos el espacio de salud de
no sin antes recordarles que en la
página web de france 24 encontrarán un
directorio con líneas de atención y de
ayuda psicológica de todos los países de
américa latina gracias por acompañarnos
de hasta aquí sigan con nosotros
[Música]